Intuitively, it should be clear
that the capacity of a cut
represents an upper bound on the amount
of flow that could go from s to t.
We state this as the following lemma.
Let f be a flow and let (A,
B) and s-t cut in a flow network.
Well then the value of the flow is
at most the capacity of the cut.
The proof goes like this.
The value of the flow is the flow
out of A minus the flow into A.
We can just drop the second term,
leaving us with just the sum
of the flows across
individual edges from A to B.
This is bounded by
the capacity of these edges.
And this sum then is
the capacity of the cut.
Note that from this proof,
the inequality will be tight if no
flow goes back from B to A and
if all the crossing edges are saturated.
That is, used to their full capacity.
Keep this in mind.